Ra
did.
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
So there you have it bitches.
Kevin Smith is in the house.
Is this is not that other version of is it?
Yeah,
I think it's per se
physician theme song.
No,
this is uh,
the gay electronic version of our theme song.
Then any s eight bit is that we can sell.
Yeah,
I want to eat a mushroom bigger.
I'm not want to step on a dragon.
Not Quite geeky enough to appreciate that tiny as it sounds like shit that made
my dick hard.
Kevin Smith is in the House,
Ladies and gentlemen,
emerging of the podcast,
two huge influences.
One you influenced me to,
to have the fleshlight sponsor the podcast.
I know what you're talking about.
I was like fucking,
I was going to jump in.
Like I can vouch for it.
I fucked many of those things.
But we also made the fleshlight legit.
Like,
if I tried to do that before you were using them as a podcast sponsor,
it'd be like,
what are you doing connecting yourself with such a vile sex toy?
Somebody had to go first.
And I'm like,
Kevin Smith has,
his whole podcast is sponsored by it.
He has these logos.
He puts up this big flashlight banners and shit.
I,
my feeling was this,
like,
women have,
uh,
you know,
something to come with for years other than me other than you something else.
And it's socially acceptable and they make fucking jokes about it on sitcoms and
shit.
We're just like,
you could go now,
my friend is here.
So in a world war that's become socially acceptable,
I felt like,
why not?
Why not vice versa?
Why can't I have something to fuck?
It's funny that we feel bad about feeling good.
We feel bad about wanting something to feel shame they build.
Yeah.
It's amazing.